this mediated relation is Lhasa
syllogism in which the individuality
initially fixed and its antithesis to
the in itself is united with this other
extreme only through a third term
through this middle term the one extreme
the unchangeable is brought into
relation with the unessential
consciousness which equally is brought
into relation with the unchangeable only
through this middle term thus the middle
term is one which presents the two
extremes to one another and ministers to
each and its dealings with the other
this middle term is itself a conscious
being the mediator for it is an action
which mediates consciousness and such
the content of this action is the
extinction of its particular
individuality which consciousness is
undertaking
the term that immediately catches the
reader's attention in this paragraph 227
is I think syllogism or in German shoes
which is as connotation of bringing
things together and holding them binding
them together and as I her mark
previously in some of the earlier videos
when you see this term of syllogism you
don't want to automatically associate
what Hagel is doing with the
Aristotelian or scholastic use of the
syllogism as you might find it in the
beginning of a logic textbook where
you've got in all these these three
propositions one of which is the
conclusion the other two of which are
the premises and there's you know very
hard and fast rules for figuring out
whether they're valid or invalid Hagel
means something a bit different he
transforms the syllogism and again as a
bedroom as i remarked if you want to see
more about that you want to look at
science of logic but we're going to skip
that right here and part so we can we
can focus on exactly what he's trying to
get it so he talks about a middle term
bringing together two extremes and that
is what occurs in a syllogism there
Hagel does have something you know
explicitly in common with Aristotle and
all of his successors so what is
actually connecting them and how is it
connecting them that's what we want to
see he says this mediated relation so
this is you know mediating relation it
is a syllogism in which individuality is
one polarity of it initially fixed in
its antithesis to the in itself the the
essential the universal is united with
this other extreme through a third term
and that's what this mediating middle
term is doing so he says through this
middle term the one extreme the
unchangeable right on this side is
brought into relation with
individuality which is the unessential
consciousness and we've seen this play
itself out already quite a bit this is
not something radically new to us and he
says thus this middle term is one which
presents the two extremes to one another
that's where it's really interesting it
presents these two extremes to it one
another it's not just a passive binding
of them this isn't a purely logical
relation as in you know concepts in our
heads or judgments or propositions that
are then align with each other we can
put down on a piece of paper what's
happening here is actually much more
dynamic the middle term itself is as
cankles going to say a conscious being
itself right and he talks about it as
ministering how the German there is
actually less verbal and more of a noun
he talks about it as a döner their
dinner they're gagan zytiga döner which
presents these two to each other or
mediates the two Dean Dean and means to
to serve to minister to take care of
it's similar to go to you know other
words in other languages that mean the
same thing that you know taking care of
so there's a relationship here where
this middle term is able to bring
together what has been throughout the
entirety of the unhappy consciousness
constantly at odds you know trying to
align with each other and then one over
you know overpowers the other or slips
elated from the other this is what can
hold them together now what happens with
that he says this middle term is a
conscious being for it is an action
which mediates consciousness as such now
what happens when that happens the
content of this action is the extinction
of its particular individuality which
consciousness is undertaking so that's a
problem and what we're going to see in
the next two paragraphs is grappling
with is this problem something that just
happen
the previous paragraphs where the
individual becomes nothing in relation
to the essential except now is happening
in terms of the middle term which is
itself a consciousness
in the mediator then this consciousness
frees itself from action and enjoyment
so far as they regard it as its own and
it's a separate independent extreme it
rejects the essence of its will and
casts upon the mediator minister priest
its own freedom of decision and here
with the responsibility for its own
action this mediator having a direct
relationship with the unchangeable being
ministers by giving advice on what is
right the action sets it follows upon
the decision of someone else ceases as
regards that doing a willing of it to be
its own there is still left to the
unessential consciousness the objective
aspect that is the fruit of its labor in
its enjoyment these there forever Jack's
as well just as it renounces its will so
ever announces the actuality it received
in work and enjoyment it renounce is
that partly as identified at the truth
that is obtained regarding its own self
conscious independence in as much as
what it does is for into it a thinking
and speaking of what is meaningless to
it partly as identified with external
possessions when it gives away part of
what it has acquired through work and
partly also as identified with the
enjoyment it has had when in its
fastings and mortifications it once more
completely denies itself that enjoyment
in paragraph 228 Hagel is working
further into the implications of this is
mediator or mediating term that he is
going to call on one hand aminta you
know means thing in the middle and also
a döner you know in a certain sense a
servant but the kind of servant that
becomes in many respects also the master
so Midler is going to translate this a
little bit periphrastic Lee as the
minister or even as the priest that's in
line with what Hagel has in mind here
given the other things that he's talking
about and given the context in which
he's writing but this could apply not
only to the historical consciousness
that's developing but but the people in
our own time who has some sort of
mediator who they're putting the
responsibility and giving their own
action their own will over towards now
he talks about these three terms again
and we're not that concerned with the
the other extreme term the unchangeable
the essential that Universal why because
the mediator is actually functioning
here to be the go-between and to speak
on part of the the unchangeable so the
unchangeable doesn't do much of anything
here instead most of the doing
interestingly enough is happening on the
side of the individual consciousness who
isn't taking responsibility for what
they are and is instead putting that on
to the mediator so let's take a look at
how this happens he says in the mediator
this consciousness frees itself from
action and enjoyment from twin and
renews insofar as they regarded as its
own so action and enjoyment are still
happening the question is where are they
happen
or who is doing the acting and who
actually gets to do the enjoyment he
goes on he says as a separate
independent extreme it rejects the
essence of its will now this is
particularly important to look at so it
continues to have its own will right
because it couldn't choose anything and
it couldn't do anything or desire
anything and actually enjoy anything if
it didn't have its own Whittle and
indeed it as we seen before a faculty of
will what it takes the essence the
vesian the being of its will and it
casts it on to the mediator so there is
there's a kind of such refuge going on
here because it has to be willing that
in order to do that but it's concealing
from itself the fact that it has done
that and it takes that to be what the
mediator itself just is or how the
mediator works in relation to the
miserable unhappy consciousness over
here so he says I cast upon the mediator
its own freedom of decision so I've cast
its freedom yeah and also responsibility
of the you know the term that's being
translated as responsibility there's I
g'nite its own particularity its own you
know selfness its own coming from itself
it places that in the hands of the
mediator and expects something else in
return so what does the meteor you the
mediator is connected with the
unchangeable it is a direct relationship
with it as opposed to indirect mediated
relationship and how does it function it
ministers by giving advice on what is is
right counseling on what is right
counseling at on what is true how the
will ought to be oriented what sort of
action ought to take place what kind of
enjoyment is licit and joy
and what kind of enjoyment is illicit or
forbidden so he says that this action
now it's the action actually on the part
of individual consciousness but it's
portrayed as coming from over here this
action since it follows on the decision
of someone else ceases as regards the
doing or the willing of it to be its own
individual consciousness gets to in this
Renaissance get himself off the foot by
saying well it's not really my decision
I'm just following the rules or I'm
following what my spiritual director is
saying or I'm following what my guru is
saying her pick whoever else you want
I'm following what you know so and so
the great master has said I ought to do
this is a one very common way of
avoiding freedom and responsibility
while using one's freedom to do that so
he goes on and he says that has to do
with the action part right what about
the enjoyment part here's where it gets
even more tangible he says there's still
left to the unessential consciousness
the objective aspect the item of the
unhappy individual consciousness works
it engages in action right it does our
body it does it does you know twin right
in German it does it does doing and
there's something that's produced by
that on it objectifies things in the
world that objectifies itself through
its labor into the world then it gets to
enjoy that right no it doesn't instead
it sacrifices it gives it up he says the
fruit of its labor and its enjoyment it
rejects these as well just as it
renounces its will it renounces the
actuality that I put your actuality of
will because it is the actuary the witla
will can be understood in several
different ways it's the faculty by which
we make choices it's also in a certain
sense the product of those choices that
is where our will is expressed so he
goes on he says he renounces this
shu ality that it is received in work
and enjoyed it renounces them partly as
identified with the truth is attained
regarding its own self conscious
independence by renouncing that portion
not only of its enjoyment but of also of
its action it's getting over again just
as it was here its freedom and
responsibility its independence it's
treating this and as if it's independent
and itself as if it's merely dependent
upon the independent being we've seen
this before right in the dialectic of
master and slave independent dependent
we've seen this before in other
conditions as well this is going to be
in a recurring dynamic so he says it r
announces them partly has identified
with this truth and even as much as it
does what is foreign to it of thinking
and speaking of what is meaningless to
so it's still willing it's still doing
it's still thinking but what is doing
for itself is the lesser part it's the
part that doesn't really matter doesn't
really make sense as we saw on previous
paragraphs is a nothingness or an
expression of nothingness in relation
not only down to the unchangeable but in
relation to the mediator who gets to do
the real thing the stuff that really
matters he goes anonyme says how does
this take place determinately as
identified with external possessions it
gives away part of what it is acquired
through work and partly also has
identified with you enjoying that has
had and its fastings and mortifications
it once more completely denies itself
that enjoyment so there's a double
movement there right it gives up part of
what it attains through its work right
to the mediator so the meteor who's
supposed to be standing in for the
unchangeable and then what it does still
possess it doesn't fully enjoy that
either because it engages in willful
practices of depriving itself
of its enjoyment fasting and
mortifications giving up things that in
a certain sense it doesn't have to give
up now this is actually going to be a
positive move although it seems very
negative as the next paragraph is going
to show us
through these moments of surrender first
of its right to decide for itself and
then of its property and enjoyment and
finally through the positive moments of
practicing what it does not understand
it truly and completely deprives itself
with the consciousness of inner and
outer freedom of the actuality in which
consciousness exists for itself it has
the certainty of having truly divested
itself of its I and I'm having turned
its immediate self consciousness into a
thing into an objective existence only
through this actual sacrifice could
demonstrate this self pronunciation for
only therein does the deception vanish
which lies in the inner acknowledgement
of gratitude through hurt sentiment and
tongue an acknowledgement which indeed
disclaims all power pertaining to its
own independent existence ascribing it
all to a gift from above but which of
this very disclaimer holds on to its own
particular existence done so awkwardly
in the possessions it does not surrender
inwardly in the consciousness of the
decision is itself made and in the
consciousness of its content which it
has itself determined which does not
exchange for one thing coming from
outside which last would fill it up with
what is meaningless for it
we've now arrived at the penultimate
paragraph of this entire section of
consciousness paragraph 229 and now
we're not looking at a dyadic
relationship of the unchangeable
consciousness on one side in individual
consciousness on the other side as we
saw through much of the unhappy
consciousness instead now it's the
mediating consciousness that's occupying
that other polarity and much of the
agency that's occurring is happening on
this side but it's still quite in a kind
of self-deception as we're going to see
that's in the process of working out so
he talks about these moments of
surrender first of the right to decide
for itself to arrive at literally
conclusions or or determinations or
judgments right inclusive and then its
own property and enjoyment and then
finally through as Miller has hear the
positive moment of practicing what it
does not understand doing what it
doesn't understand because the mediating
consciousness says well you need to do
this it gives the council's we saw in
the last paragraph what happens there's
a sacrifice on the part of the subject
going on the subject who is the
individual consciousness now the
individual consciousness as Hagel's
saying comes to no longer treat itself
in doing so as an eye and we saw that
there's a bit of you know self-deception
involved there it is willing it is you
know doing this on its own side but it's
concealing from itself its own
involvement in that and instead treats
itself as Hagel says as a thing now
that's not a facade that it can truly be
maintained so he says
it deprives itself of the consciousness
of inner and outer freedom through all
of these different you know
transformations and and you know at
negations that we've seen what it is
doing in what consciousness is doing is
using its freedom using the freedom that
it actually does possess to deprive
itself of its inner freedom its freedom
of willing its freedom of coming to
conclusions and it's our freedom the
external products of its freedom not
only in terms of giving up some of its
property but even in terms of enjoying
what it is derived through the fruits of
its own work so can this be maintained
he says it has a certainty of having
truly divest of it divested itself of
its I it lets the mediator be the one
who gets to say I it treats itself as a
thing turned its immediate
self-consciousness into a thing into an
objective existence again we have seen
this process working itself out
something similar occurred in the
earlier dialectics in this section right
so then it says only through this actual
sacrifice could it demonstrate this self
pronunciation so you could say well why
go through all this this you know
dialectical movement and hiding from
itself the fact that in itself is the
consciousness on all the different size
why doesn't it just cut to the chase
well it needed to work through all of
this in order to be able to arrive at
the other side there's no shortcut you
could say within the Galleon dialectic
not even if her office in processing it
well maybe there is a shortcut and that
Hagel gave us the blue friend and the
road map right assuming that he's
actually taking us on the right path big
assumption sign that's a sight count so
you go somebody says they're in the
deception vanishes which lies in the
inner acknowledgement of gratitude what
is he talking about there well remember
that we saw
when there is the expression of things
the giving of things that giving itself
is a thanks in relation to another
giving that is supposed to have preceded
it and the expression of gratitude is
supposed to be an acknowledgement of
dependency and acknowledgement that the
essential is on the other side and one
is just you know this this lowly worm
that has nothing to bring to the table
oh thank you for giving me faculties
that I can use to do things thank you
for giving me the very gifts of the
possibilities etc etc we can go on and
on and on I am I am not worthy right is
the sense but a really gratitude itself
and the giving of thanks as we saw it
earlier passages conceals the fact that
the initiative comes on the side of the
one who shows gratitude and the one who
shows graduate in certain respects is
greater than the one who gives so there
was a deception involved there as he
says it's a deception that has to do
with these three modalities of heart we
saw how important the sentiment of the
heart was and then there's sentiment
itself right and then there is
expression in Miller's translation its
tongue but it's literally a driven one
right so verbal expression and think
about what devotion involves there is
the heart itself you know the feeling
there is the way that one is you know
thinking about this the computed in this
and then there is the mouth of the
verbal expression what it is that one is
saying what one is doing with that organ
all right so this allows that that
deception to be stripped away to be
overcome it says an acknowledgement
which disclaims all power pertaining to
its own independent existence ascribing
it all to a gift from above but which in
this very disclaimer holds on to its
particular existence so this is a very
important point instead of just treating
itself as a thing has a mere object
which is impossible anyway right because
a subject can't merely be an object in
so far as it as understanding as itself
as an object is it is acting as a
subject in them very thinking and that
very judging and that you're even
feeling itself to be merely an object so
it does hold on to its own particular
existence it holds something back the
sacrifice is as complete as it could be
because not everything can be stripped
away or annul applied in the process
what does it hold on to it holds on to
some of its property so the you know if
we put this in terms of religious belief
in action on the religious believer
gives us some of these property to the
religious institution whether it be the
church or the you know the community you
know we'll pick whatever you like right
same thing in any any particular
religion the temple good water right so
they give up some of their property but
they hold on to some of them the some of
it that they're allowed to keep because
they've given up there you know freedom
of making that judgment to the mediator
they get to enjoy some of it and some of
it they don't get to enjoy they have to
give some of it up in fasting or
mortification or just not practicing
certain things right well they do get to
enjoy some of it and that some of it
that they do get to enjoy is thurs that
is part of their particular existence
they are not just a thing in doing so
even if they are acting as we saw it
earlier passages like you know what they
think to be at merely animal existence
in so far as they can feel themselves to
be living a merely the animal existence
they are not merely animals right we can
also talk in terms of decision then now
this is where we get to the
root of the deception right so they gave
up the right to decide for themselves or
did they were they making a decision in
giving up the right to decide for
themselves or were they deciding that
that was a good thing to do when
somebody calls them to questions is why
are you listening to those priests why
are you listening those ministers why
are you listening to the Imam they
actually say I think that's a good thing
for me to do they don't just say wow you
know I'm saying I can't do nothing but
but be a thing they say well I think
that that's the better path for me
insofar as they're doing that they have
reserved some of their own judgment had
a thing and that as higgles have talked
about in this kind of particularly
peculiar way they reserved some of the
content what does that mean that in all
right he says they have a reserve this
consciousness of its content which it is
itself determined what does it mean
that's identity that's who one is
through what one does and what one
desires and one enjoys the content of
consciousness what is conscious of this
content but that consciousness is a
consciousness of the content of
consciousness one is conscious of what
one is actually doing what what is done
what was intending to do what is
conscious of the desires the wheeling
the choices the directionality we could
say one is conscious of the things that
one actually has in one's life whether
it be a tie or you know pair of glasses
or a chalkboard those are still hard for
me part of my consciousness no matter
even if i decided i'm going to do these
for the greater glory of Hegel right and
I give everything up to a goal to be the
great media which is one way you could
look at this I'm still one who holds on
to this I'm the one who's shooting this
video and the subterfuge or deception as
i've called it so far is the concealment
to the fact that one is actually doing
that the person the subject is
not just a thing the individual is not
just a thing but it is a subject just
like the eye of the mediator so he goes
on when he says it hasn't exchange this
content for one coming from the outside
which would just fill it up with what is
meaningless for it instead if it thinks
about it its own content is in fact
meaningful for it